hey everyone Joey here and welcome to
the first episode or first lesson rather
of economics in this video I'm going to
be showing you how to move and how to
traverse the terrain how to get around
in splatoon - and this will be the first
video of a two or three part series
depending on if you guys are interested
the second lesson will focus more on
weapons so make sure to subscribe to our
channel if you haven't already so you
don't miss that one but for right now
we're gonna be talking about movement
and movement is probably the most
crucial thing in splatoon - it doesn't
matter how good of a shot you are or how
accurate you are with your guns if you
can't maneuver well you're gonna have
some problems and this applies to all
modes multiplayer battles salmon runs
single-player everything requires
precise movement and I'm going to show
you so my favorite tips and practices to
move around in the game alright let's go
alright so the first topic we're going
to be talking about here is swimming and
so just like the original splatoon if
you have ink underneath you you can
press the Z trigger to dive down and you
can swim around in it and now what that
does is it will give you a little bit of
speed boost you can travel a lot faster
here as you can see but it also makes
you hidden now you're not completely
invisible as you can see there's a
little bit of a wave as I'm moving
around in it but for the most part
you're gonna be you're not gonna be
spotted you know to the naked eye or
from afar so you wanted to do that as
often as possible
anytime you're not shooting you want to
be diving down to the ink and moving
around and now what you want to do with
this though is combine this with your
inking strategy so as you know you can
only swim in ink of your own color and
so what you'll want to be doing when you
have spots that are uh named
or are inked by the enemy you want to be
swimming and then you want to be popping
out shooting ahead of you and then
swimming again so let me reset this what
you want to be doing is inking diving
down popping up and then inking again
and then popping down or diving down
popping up and you want to repeat this
process because this will get you from
point A to point B as quickly as
possible you can see I do a little jump
in there and that's mostly because
you know just it's a personal thing it
kind of helps with my rhythm you know
the game is very rhythmic you know not
only the music but like just the flow of
the matches and the characters so you
want to be so what I like doing is just
jumping up shooting it diving down
jumping up shooting I'm not sure exactly
if it gives you more distance your shot
I still have to look at the numbers but
um you know either way I'm going to be
diving down hugging back up and then
shooting you you don't need to worry too
much about these small gaps in the ink
that I have so like between right here
for example you can swim right through
that and it won't slow you down too much
but if there are like bigger gaps like
this you might have a little bit of
problem going through it you can see you
like that
you can see the squid actually right
there but for the most part just smaller
gaps don't worry too much about it is
you can just you know swim straight
through it alright so for topic two
we're gonna be talking about engaging
and avoiding so you know movement is not
only about getting to one place as fast
as possible that is important but what
might be even more important at times is
the ability to get away from everyone
you know if you come across an inkling
with a special on deck you can see
they're blowing air right here if they
have that or that back up or if they or
if you're just in their own territory
and the non lager ink is on the ground
you want to be able to get away as fast
as possible one of the things that I
like doing is looking for a higher
ground so for example if you're being
chased right here and you see a little
ledge like this you can ink the sides
and swim up and then you have like a
good job though good shot at them from a
bucket above here another thing that you
can do is use the the bonds or your sub
weapons so for example the Aero spray
here has the suction bomb so what I like
doing while I'm being chased by someone
is swimming laying a bomb down and then
continuing to swim and that way they
they won't be able to follow me or they
won't be able to be right on my tail you
know they're gonna have to watch out for
the bomb so they don't get spotted
and then one of the other things I want
to mention is that the the method for
inking you know diving down to the ink
jumping up inking diving down again that
works just as well for when you're
trying to get away probably even more so
probably even more important to do that
when you're getting away because you got
to be fast if you're swimming through
other people's ink you want to make sure
you have a path and so you want to be
jump up ink dive down as soon as
possible you know you want you want to
try to get away and try to find your
teammates group up with them and then
gang up on the other guy that was
shooting at you and the third topic
we're going to be talking about here is
vertical movement and now I touched on
this just a little bit earlier about you
know inking a wall and then climbing up
to get a get a better shot at someone
from from above but just overall
vertical movement in this game is very
very important and you want to make sure
to utilize it as as often as possible so
what you can do is you can ink a wall
and then swim up it just like that to
get to higher grounds but what what you
always want to be doing when you when
you're swimming up is make sure you're
mashing be mashing the jump button to
make sure you swim faster I see this a
lot and some people just kind of might
okay it will kind of slip your mind
sometimes when you're when you're
swimming because you know you don't
press B except to jump out like that so
it kind of makes sense suggesting you'll
swim up at the same rate but you can see
the difference here in the speed this is
me swimming without pressing form
without mashing B looks like that and
this is with me mashing you know you can
hear that that little squishy sound you
know of your of yourself mashing B and
you'll swim much faster going uphill or
going up walls it's one of my favorite
things to do another thing I really like
doing is utilizing the walls for sneak
attacks if you for example are being
chased by someone and you go around the
wall and you this wall is empty or it
has your ink color what you can do is go
like this go around the corner and then
immediately jump onto
wall and you can kind of a kind of fill
with the with the up direction kind of
just hold it up for a second and then
let go kind of stay in one place and
that way if they come around the corner
they're going to be expecting you to be
here at some point but if you go around
they're not gonna be able to see this
and jump onto the wall you can wait for
them to come around we just completely
confuse as to where you went pop out and
then splat them it's the the game is
very much built around sneak attacks
you know just hiding in ink and waiting
and so doing that on the walls is
probably one of the most uh clever
things you can do alright so thanks for
watching I hope you guys learned a thing
or two about movement in the game you
know it's gonna take a little bit of
practice but once you get once you get
going and once you know how to move
you're gonna have a really great time in
in splatoon too now if you guys enjoyed
this video leave a like or even
subscribe to the channel if you want to
catch our second lesson in which I'll be
talking about the weapons in the game
but for now I'll leave you with a little
bit of gameplay from one of my matches
so you can study that and be ready for
the next lesson all right I'll see you
guys then
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]